imaginez qu'on puisse soigner le cerveau
sans médicaments eh bien il existe une
technologie qui à presque 100 ans
aujourd'hui et qui s'apprête à
révolutionner les neurosciences tout a
commencé avec cet homme entre bergen en
1924 en posant des électrodes sur la
tête de ces sujets il observe pour la
première fois les oscillations
électriques du cerveau
l'électroencéphalographie était né alors
si vous avez aujourd'hui dans un hôpital
où on utilise cette technique de manière
quotidienne pour le diagnostic des
maladies psychiatriques et neurologiques
et bien vous serez peut-être surpris de
réaliser que en fait depuis cette date
très peu a changé et voilà comment ça se
passe un premier spécialiste comme on le
voit sur cette image vient installer
individuellement une vingtaine de
capteurs sur la tête des patients les
signaux sont ensuite amplifié
enregistrés et un deuxième spécialiste
typiquement un neurologue va venir
interpréter ces signaux que vous voyez
et pour les interpréter il tire deux
informations importantes
la première la fréquence et l'amplitude
des oscillations électriques du cerveau
renseigne sur le niveau d'activité
cérébrale
on dit que les fréquences qui sont
élevés c'est à dire les oscillations qui
sont rapides s'associe avec une activité
cérébrale et que les oscillations qui
sont plus lentes s'associer avec un
repos cérébrale
maintenant la position de l'électrode
renseigne sur différentes aires
cérébrales et aujourd'hui on sait
distinguer environ une cinquantaine
d'heures cérébrale et chacune s'associe
avec une fonction particulière en
combinant donc ces informations des
fonctions cérébrales avec leur
activation et leur désactivation
on a avec l'électro encéphalographie
cette technique un outil extrêmement
puissant pour analyser le cerveau et
vous allez me dire s'il est si puissant
comment ça se fait qu'on n'entendra plus
parler et vous avez raison c'est une
excellente question et j'y viens la
première fois que j'ai utilisé cette
technique
c'était il ya dix ans à cette époque
j'étais responsable d'un projet de
recherche qui avait pour objectif de
rendre la communication à des patients
atteints de troubles moteurs sévère il
s'agit de quelques dizaines de patients
en france seulement et leur besoin
d'être technique est évidemment
extrêmement important et donc avec un
groupe de chercheurs français
on a décidé d'utiliser une technique qui
étaient utilisés dans les laboratoires
de recherche développé depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années dans de nombreux
laboratoires à travers le monde et en
particulier un ici à rennes qui
s'appelle l'inria et on voulait prendre
cette technique les interfaces cerveau
ordinateur dans les laboratoires de
recherche et les transférer au chevet
des patients
là où ils peuvent être utilisés et voilà
les résultats de ce projet de recherche
on voit ici michael tu y as un patient
qui a eu un accident vasculaire cérébral
qui utilise un casque un logiciel et des
algorithmes qui ont été développés dans
le cadre de ce projet et qui
communiquent entre guillemets avec la
pensée et faire ça
était en soi une vraie prouesse
technologique et pourtant pour moi après
ces cinq années de recherches
ça a été une vraie déception de voir que
ces patients n'utilise pas cette
technologie et ils utilisent pas parce
qu'il ya d'autres outils qui sont soient
plus simples soient plus efficaces
soient moins chers comme par exemple
l'eye tracking qui permet de faire le
suivi du regard qui leur permet de faire
mieux mais heureusement ça s'est pas
arrêté là et ça s'est pas arrêté là
parce que la technologie qui a été
développée pour répondre aux besoins de
ces quelques patients est bien là où
vers des applications qui vise un public
beaucoup plus large et ça il ya une
dizaine d'années ça a attisé la
curiosité des industriels qui sont en
train aujourd'hui d'opérer la révolution
des neurosciences et cette révolution
des neurosciences elle s'accélère depuis
cinq ans autour de deux avancées
technologiques fondamentale
la première c'est celle de la mesure de
l'activité cérébrale
on voit que depuis sa création en 1920
jusqu'au début des années 2000 et encore
aujourd'hui à l'hôpital
et bien la technique elle a très peu
progressé il ya dix ans dans les
laboratoires de recherche il fallait
mettre des espèces de bonnets de piscine
avec des fils partout connecter sa à un
boîtier qui coûtent plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'euros
c'était long fastidieux très cher
aujourd'hui il est possible en 2016 pour
quelques centaines d'euros d'enregistrer
de manière extrêmement fiable l'activité
du cerveau dans n'importe quel contexte
maintenant pour l'analyse et bien les
neurosciences au même titre que beaucoup
d'autres domaines de la médecine ont
bénéficié des progrès en intelligence
artificielle et en mathématiques
appliquées avec ces techniques on peut
aujourd'hui automatisée des procédures
qui nécessitait hier la présence d'un
expert pour l'interprétation des
résultats
par exemple on va utiliser une technique
qui est assez similaire à celle
qu'utilisent les géologues pour
localiser l'épicentre d'un séisme
avec cette technique à partir des
capteurs qui sont la surface de la tête
on est capable de quantifier avec
précision l'activité dans plus d'une
centaine de zones à l'intérieur du
cerveau et voilà ce qu'on obtient quand
on applique cette technique en temps
réel donc la révolution des
neurosciences aujourd'hui en 2016
c'est ça c'est la convergence d'une
mesure simple efficace bon marché
utilisable par n'importe qui n'importe
où et qui s'associe avec des outils d
analyse extrêmement puissant et
complètement automatique
et c'est tellement une réalité qu'il y a
à travers le monde des dizaines
d'entreprises qui s'apprête à
commercialiser des produits sur la base
de ces deux avancées technologiques dans
cet exemple on voit un pilote d'avion
qui est équipé d'un casque
électroencéphalographique et à partir de
ces tracés cérébraux on est capable
d'extraire des informations sur sa
vigilance c'est à dire est ce qu'il est
en train de s'endormir
par exemple son niveau de charge mentale
c'est à dire est ce qu'il est dépassé
par les évènements ou voir même son
stress et vous imaginez à quel point
l'arrivée d'un dispositif comme ça va
pouvoir améliorer la sécurité aérienne
mais ça n'est pas tout parce que la
promesse de cette technologie
aujourd'hui elle va bien au delà elle va
au delà parce qu'elle offre la promesse
de soigner le cerveau sans médicaments
et vous allez me dire soigner le cerveau
sans médicaments c'est certainement pas
très banal ni commun et pourtant si vous
vous blesser à la jambe et que vous
allez voir votre médecin il va pas
nécessairement automatiquement vous
donner un cachet pour réparer votre
jambe
en revanche il va vous envoyer chez le
kiné et le kid et qu'est ce qu'il va
faire eh bien il va vous montrer un
mouvement qui implique les muscles à
rééduquer
par exemple la flexion du genou et vous
de séance en séance vous allez regarder
cette fiction du genou et essayer de
l'amplifier pour rééduquer les must et
soigner les muscles qui sont à rééduquer
eh bien c'est exactement ce que permet
faire l'électroencéphalographie avec une
technique qui s'appelle le neurofeedback
et il ya énormément d'applications du
nord au feedback aujourd'hui est plutôt
que vous faire une liste longue de tout
ce qu'elle pouvait faire
je voudrais illustrer à quel point c'est
concret avec deux dispositifs qui ont
été conçus développés ici en france et
qui s'apprête à être commercialisé le
premier c'est ce dispositif pour le
grand public qui permet de mieux gérer
son stress au quotidien
et comment est ce qu'il fait ça eh bien
il le fait en donnant en montrant une
représentation auditive de l'activité
cérébrale qui est associé à la
relaxation et voilà comment ça se passe
on voit ici le niveau de relaxation en
bas des modifications de la musique qui
sont associés à partir de lundi vitesse
en aval
en utilisant ce dispositif
au quotidien on peut donc ré entraîner
ces aires cérébrales et mieux gérer son
stress au quotidien
la deuxième application que je vais vous
présenter
c'est un dispositif sur lequel je
travaille en ce moment avec un groupe
vraiment talentueux d'ingénieurs qui est
un dispositif médical et je serais
curieux de savoir combien parmi vous
connaissent directement ou indirectement
des enfants qui sont atteints de
troubles de l'inattention avec ou sans
hyperactivité
je vois qu'il ya quelques têtes qui se
chevauchent quelques mains qui se lèvent
il y en a un petit peu quand même
c'est une pathologie qui est
particulièrement mal connue et mal
diagnostiqués en france dès on estime
qu'il ya entre un à deux élèves par
classe qui sont concernés avec un impact
fort sur le parcours scolaire et des
vraies difficultés à la maison avec le
neurofeedback on va proposer à ses
enfants de jouer un jeu vidéo qui est
modulé par l'activité cérébrale
responsable de l'inattention de sorte
qu'ils puissent au quotidien la ré
entraîner et voilà comment ça se
présente
on voit en haut à droite l'activité
cérébrale instantanée enregistre à la
surface de la tête et juste en dessous
une représentation instantanée des airs
ou de l'activité cérébrale associée avec
l'inattention et on va demander à
l'enfant de contrôler cette activité de
la maintenir dans certaines zones de
tolérance et lui l'enfant ne voit que la
partie qui à gauche c'est à dire le
petit bateau de pêche est là pour
mission de pêcher des poissons mais il
ne peut empêcher ces poissons que
lorsque son niveau d'attention
d'inattention cérébrale est maintenu en
dessous d'un certain seuil les études
cliniques montrent qu'après typiquement
une trentaine de séances espacées sur
plusieurs semaines
les enfants qui arrivent à contrôler
cette activité serré
hal est bien la soci avec une réduction
durable des symptômes
certaines études montrent même que cette
réduction de symptômes
elle peut durer jusqu'à deux ans après
l'arrêt du traitement
donc pour ses enfants et pour leur
famille et bien
l'électroencéphalographie avec le
neurofeedback aujourd'hui en 2016 peut
vraiment faire la différence
elle constitue une alternative crédible
aux médicaments le médicament c'est une
pilule qui doit être pris deux fois par
jour une fois le matin une fois le soir
une fois le midi c'est un traitement
qu'ils aient continué souvent jusqu'à
l'âge adulte donc est pris pendant de
plusieurs années et qui s'associe
malheureusement parfois d'effets
secondaires
voilà ce que permet de faire aujourd'hui
en 2016 l'électroencéphalographie à la
vitesse à laquelle vont les choses c'est
difficile de savoir ce qu'elle pourra
faire dans cinq ou dans dix ans en
revanche il ya deux choses
bon moi je suis convaincu la première
c'est que vous allez de plus en plus
vous faire proposer des dispositifs de
ce type
j'espère que vous savez à présent que ce
ne sont pas des jouets et qu'il modifie
vraiment votre activité cérébrale et
donc avant de les utiliser peut-être
réfléchissez un ace que j'ai vraiment
envie de me changer
la deuxième chose c'est que cette
technologie elle va continuer de
progresser et elle va continuer de faire
plus pour les populations qui sont moins
nombreuses et je pense en particulier à
ses patients pour lesquels on veut
toujours améliorer la communication
merci pour votre attention